Alles klar, 60 Sekunden zum Auftritt.
Okay, ich trink noch was kurz.
Bla, bra, bra. Boah, Alter, ey. Die Bühne ist sehr rutschig, ist dir das aufgefallen? Ich war vorhin mal drauf, die Bühne ist extrem. Lach, lach, ich kann nicht hören, weil ich gerade meine Übungen mache. Bra, bra, Brom, Brom, Brom, Brom, Brom, Brom. Ich hab nichts zu Brom, bitte sprich nicht über Rom. Xenon,on, Radon, 30 Sekunden, Quecksilber, Queck, Queck, Ma, Ma, Ma, Ma, Ma, Ma, okay, okay, 15, beginn mit diesem Gag über Plastikflaschen und Pfannenflaschen, okay, alles klar, Steff, komm, wir machen das jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, es gehen wir raus und wir rocken die Halle. Wir sind das Podcast UFO, Podcast Geisterbahn.
Okay, und drei, zwei, eins. Das Podcast. Das Podcast. Kass, U, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, Ho, denn alle? Ja, wo kann ich mal eure Hände sehen? Es ist nur die Frage, wie man das sagt. Ich glaube, es ist eigentlich eins zu eins Kasperle-Sprech. Ich glaube, es ist auch daraus entstanden. Kasperle. Wow! Heisst du das neue Album von Kasper, Kasperle-The Theater? Alter, Stefan, du haust halt einen nach dem anderen drauf. Nee, komm. Herzlich willkommen beim Podcast UFO. Dieses Intro wurde uns präsentiert von Fritz Frittenfett. Vielen Dank an ihn für dieses geniale Intro und vielen Dank an alle anderen, die auch bis jetzt Intros eingeschickt haben. Wir haben jetzt jede Woche ein neues Intro. Wie nimmt uns Fritz Frittenfett wahr? Also sind wir für ihn so Klubber? Also es ist offensichtlich nicht so weit weg zum Podium und macht die Hände hoch. Ich weiß nicht, ob es so Klubber ist. Ich glaube, du warst auch schon lange nicht mehr in einem Klubmuskel. Ja, ganz gut. Ich habe so eine Erinnerung. Du hast auch immer so Sketche vorgeschlagen, so, ey, dann sind die Leute im Klub und dann haben die irgendwie alle... Man versteht, was du meinst. Man versteht, was was du meinst. Aber ich finde das Beste daran, dass wir jetzt immer Intros von anderen Leuten haben, ist eigentlich, dass man mal sieht, wie die uns wahrnehmen. Also da kommen noch ganz tolle Sachen, wir haben eben ein paar zum Proben gehört quasi vorher, da kommen noch tolle Sachen auf euch zu. Manche so jazzig und sich fragt okay, Humor, Humor, also wie Humor-Jazz
quasi, Comedy-Jazz für die.
Klickt euch jetzt einfach mal, falls ihr jetzt irgendwie im August
2020 hört, einfach mal durch den Anfang
der nächsten Folgen. Ich garantiere euch,
der Anfang wird das Beste der Folge sein.
Die Intros, die wir bekommen haben, sind grossartig.
Sind fantastisch. Stefan, ich freue mich wieder, dass wir uns
sehen. Nein, ich freue mich, dich zu sehen.
Nein, aber es ist ja auch so,
du hast so ein erfolgreiches Leben und du hast so ein tolles Leben und man denkt sich immer so, wenn ich zu Hause irgendwie liege und Geld zähle, dann denke ich mir immer so, boah, der Stefan, der macht das bestimmt was total genau. Ja, weil er Geld braucht, weil er da hinkommen will, irgendwann mal Geld zu zählen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber es ist fantastisch, ey, mein Leben ist gerade so, also ich muss echt sagen, ich bin richtig glücklich. Ernsthaft? Ist es die neue Phase von Stefan T? Die gl die Glücklichphase? Glaubst du, du bist jemals an einem Punkt, wo du sagst, jetzt bin ich richtig glücklich? Ich kam mir auch fast schlecht vor, das zu sagen. Also ich war noch nie, warst du schon mal richtig glücklich? Ich glaube, das ist ja so das Ding, dass man in dem Moment, in dem man glücklich ist, das selber nicht wahrnimmt, weil man keine Selbsteinschätzung so hat, weil man einfach geniesst und im Universum aufgeht. Klar. Und das erste Rückwirkende. Aber es gab einen Moment, wo ich rückblickend schon glücklich war. Es war in Berlin. Da bin ich die U-Bahn-Treppe hochgelaufen und ich bin aus Köln gekommen. Aus Köln fährst du ja in den Untergrund in Berlin, in den Unterbahnhof. Das heißt, es gibt einige Gleise. Der Unterirdische Bahnhof. Das heißt, du siehst relativ lange die Außenwelt nicht. Und dann bin ich hochgelaufen. Und du weißt nicht, bin ich in Berlin? Und dann siehst du Berlin und denkst dir, yes! Und dann bin ich noch mit der U-Bahn gefahren. Das heißt, ich habe bestimmt zehn Minuten am Stück nicht die Oberfläche gesehen. Und dann bin ich die U-Bahn-Treppe hochgelaufen, hatte einen geilen Song auf dem Ohr, schön David Guetta im Ohr. Und dann bin ich hochgelaufen und es hat geschneit. Es hat in der Zeit, in der ich unterirdisch war, angefangen hat zu schneien. Und es war so richtig Puderzucker über den Strassen und ich kam gerade zurück aus Köln, vom Niermagazin, das war noch ganz am Anfang. Ich war glücklich, ich habe was geleistet, ich habe was erreicht, ich komme in Berlin an, irgendwie so diese eiskalte Nachtluft steigt mir in die Nase und der Schnee kommt da. Und es war so richtig so, wo ich dachte, so ja, das hat so zwei, drei Sekunden gedauert und dann war man natürlich wieder im zynischen, alten Zuhause angekommen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und dann verfliegt sowas schnell, aber naja.
Nee, wirklich, also ich habe auch mittlerweile das Gefühl, vielleicht bin ich einfach nicht dafür, also mein Gehirn ist vielleicht nicht dafür gemacht, vielleicht habe ich irgendwie so eine, ich denke auch, vielleicht habe ich so eine ganz schwere Krankheit und kann keine Freude wahrnehmen.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Fun-Podcast.
Hey, Gags, Gags, Gags, schön, dass ihr da seid. Wenn wir wirklich nicht so wären, wenn dann das Mikro an, also wenn man, das Mikro ist schon ein bisschen leer an und man hört so, ich weiß nicht, ob ich wirklich Freude empfinden kann. Und ihr seid drauf in drei, zwei, eins, hey, herzlich willkommen zum Fun-Fun-Fun-Podcast. Ich bin in letzter Zeit immer so ein bisschen nervös, weil ich habe irgendwie immer so ein bisschen Probleme im Hintergrund. So, und eigentlich Probleme im Hintergrund. So, es gibt ja das Problem mit dem... Steuerschulden sind nicht Hintergrund. Haben wir schon ein paar Mal gesagt. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Aber den Running-Gag gehört mein Steuerberater nicht so gern, muss ich ganz ehrlich auch machen. Meine Anwälte auch nicht. Aber es ist so... Meine Anwälte, das ist auch schon so ein Punkt, das ist Plural bei uns, sorry. Stimmt, das ist interessant. Wann ist der Punkt erreicht, wo man sagt, Rudi, du reichst mir nicht. Aber wenn man einen Gag macht mit, ja, meine Anwälten gefällt das auch nicht, denkt man auch immer so, dann bist du schon, der Gag ist so richtig, weil wenn du so was sagst, hast du offensichtlich Anwälte. Warum solltest du sonst Plural sprechen? Und dann ist der Gag auch nicht relatable mehr, weil dann bist du nicht mehr relatable. Auf jeden Fall hatte ich eine Mate zu Hause im Eisschrank und ich war unterwegs und habe meine Mate im Eisschrank vergessen und wusste die ganze Zeit, okay, zu Hause explodiert gleich mein Eisschrank, die Mate ist weg, die Flasche ist geplatzt, die Mate ist gefroren, Kühlschrank ist weg, Eiswach ist weg, die Prinzessinbohnen, Prinzessbohnen, wie heisst die, Prinzessinbohnen, daneben, alles kontaminiert, alles Kollateralschaden, alles weg, tatsächlich, da sind... Wenn du so einen Fernseher siehst, irgendwo, du läufst so durch Berlin, irgendwie, und dann guckst du in so ein Schaufenster und die Nachrichten laufen gerade, und man sieht so eine große Explosion, die gerade über Köln in der Gefängnis ist, einfach... Weil niemand hat bisher Mate in den Kühlschrank gelegt und du wusstest, was die Effekte sind. Ich glaube, irgendwo habe ich das schon mal erzählt, aber es war in meiner Schulzeit, es ist tatsächlich passiert, dass mir eine Speziflasche explodiert ist. Also nicht mir konkret, sondern einem Freund von mir. Die ist geplatzt einfach, nicht irgendwie durch Eis oder frost. Aber zerberstet oder geplatzt? Nee, wirklich, also wirklich explodiert. Und es war wirklich so, dass er, wir hatten da immer so eine Ecke, es war glaube ich in der Schulzeit immer so, dass man in der Pause hatte jeder seine Ecke. Das ergibt sich auch einfach so. Das ist so, ich denke mir irgendwie so, heiliges römisches Reich, deutsche Nationen, jeder hat so seinen eigenen kleinen fetzen Land, wie ergibt sich das? Ja. So, sagt man einfach bei Risiko, man würfelt es aus und dann startet man und dann sagt man, okay, jeder hat halt. Nee, oft war es glaube ich so, nee, wir wollen jetzt hier bleiben, ich kann auch gehen, und hier ist ein schöner Fluss, und hier ist eine Mündung, hier kann man sich hinsetzen, hier ist eine Furt. Ja, aber die Menschen sind ja nicht so gleichmäßig verteilt. Wie nennen wir diese Stadt, Frank? Ja, Furt. So, und dann sind die da geblieben, andere wollten noch weitergehen, dachten, das Paradies kommt noch, und sind dann weiter flussaufwärts gegangen. Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall schwierig und jedenfalls ist es in der großen Pause auch so ein bisschen so jeder. Und dann gibt es manchmal so Flüchtlingsströme, irgendwann mal eine neue Klasse, doppelter Jahrgang. Oh, war natürlich bei mir G8, G9. Bei euch auch? Intensiv, natürlich plötzlich waren doppelt so viele Schüler da. Wann hast du Abi gemacht? 2010. Warum war da schon bei uns? Ach, du bist ein anderes Bundesrat. Ich war der letzte Jahrgang, der noch G9 war. Ich war der erste Jahrgang, der G8 war. Ah, guck mal, das heißt, du bist zwei Jahre jünger, oder nicht? Nee, drei. Ich war 2013, habe ich aber gemacht. Das kannst du daraus dann nicht ableiten. Naja, gut. Auf jeden Fall, es war dann wirklich so, wir hatten jeder unsere eigene Ecke und wir hatten irgendwann, hatten wir so ein Getränkeautomat in der Schule. Natürlich, klar, haben wir uns was gezogen, haben wir uns was reingestellt, haben wir uns was rausgelassen, je nachdem. Und dann hatten wir mal in unserer Sitzgruppe, hatten wir dann so eine Speziflasche, die da stand harmlos und einfach plötzlich explodiert ist. Und ein Freund von mir saß da so kniend davor, also dieses so. Hat sie angebetet, die heiligen Pepsi-Gott. Wie heißt diese Pose, wenn man, man hat die Fusssohlen auf dem Boden stehen, glaube ich. Man hat beide Fusssohlen auf dem Boden. Ich verstehe, Hocken meinst du? Nee, aber beim Hocken ist das Gesäss nicht auf dem Boden. Ist beim Hocken, sind die Fersen oben oder unten? Beim Hocken. Hocken, was ist nochmal Hocken? Hocken ist, warte. Hocken ist das. Ja, aber Gesäß nicht auf dem Boden. Jetzt tu mal gesäß auf dem Boden jetzt. Tu mal gesäß auf dem Boden jetzt. Was? Aha, und ja genau so. Genau so. Wie heißt das? Kauern. Er kauerte vor der Pepsi-Flasche. Wir sitzen ist das Wort. Ich Ich weiß, mein Blowing. Ja, die Sitzen, ich weiß es nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall, probiert das zu Hause mal aus, vielleicht kommt ihr drauf. Nee, also du meinst Gesäss, dann angewinkelte Beine, die Hände umschlingen die Knie. Ja, das ist natürlich eine Variation. Also die Hände können die Knie umschlingen, auch oft, sag ich mal. Aber Tipp, es sieht einsam aus. Es sieht immer so aus, als ob ihr mit euren Knien am besten befreundet seid.
Ich glaube, die Variation, die es häufig gibt,
ich sehe es bei jungen Frauen manchmal,
dass wenn man einen Pullover anhat, der sehr weit ist,
dass man dann den Pullover auch noch über die Knie stillt. Das finde ich super gut.
Super gut, ja. Super gute Position.
Also tolle Sitzposition, glaube ich, ich könnte empfehlen.
Das finde ich bei Frauen süss.
Ich finde es einfach süss, wenn die das machen. Die aussehen wie so kleine Pulloverbälle. Das finde ich bei Frauen süss. Ich finde es einfach süss, wenn die das machen.
Sie aussehen wie so kleine Pulloverbälle.
Das finde ich einfach ganz toll.
Also wenn ihr mich beeindrucken wollt als Frau, dann gerne ...
Entschuldigung, das ist mein Klingelton.
Nee, das ist der Klingelton, selber.
Oh, meine Freundin ruft mich gerade an.
Sorry.
Entschuldigung.
Ganz ruhig, mach kurz weiter, überrühr kurz. Nee, sicher nicht. Ist die eine Folge, wo wir nicht schneiden wollen, Florentin. Bin gleich zuhause. Baby. Schatz, stell schon mal den Champagner kalt. Hab dir was Wichtiges zu erzählen. Und zieh den Pullover an. Und zieh den großen Pullover an. Du weißt, wie ich es am liebsten habe. Zieh schön über deine Knie. Die sollte uns nicht mehr stören, die nächsten 45 Minuten. Sorry, ich habe irgendwie echt harten Scheisse auf meinen Kopf. Das Signal flackert konstant zwischen links und rechts bei mir gerade. Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist. Es ist ganz merkwürdig. Naja. Egal, wo war das nochmal? Ich dachte, das lasst mal meine Witze die ganze Zeit. Die Sitzposition. Die Sitzposition. Ich sage, wenn man zumindest den Pullover nicht über die Schienbeine stülpt, dann sind die Schienbeine frei und verwundbar. Kurze Hose, es war im Sommer, die Schienbeine waren frei und verwundbar. Über Schienbeine möchte ich gleich auch nochmal reden, das ist auch so ein Thema von mir. Schienbeine waren komplett frei. Und Skibeine. Und plötzlich explodierte die Speziflasche und er hatte wirklich, ich glaube drei, vier Glassplitter in sein Schienbein. Glassplitter? Ach, eine Glasflasche. Glas the ... Glasflasche. Was zum Teufel? Und wirklich wie eine Granate, wie Schrapnell, sind die in seine Schienbeine gefahren. Und ich sass zum Glück hinter meinem Schulranzen, hatte in meinem Schulranzen Glassplitter drin, sind wir natürlich sofort zum Schulnotdienstschul. Ja, halt irgendwie die drei unbeliebtesten Kinder der Klasse, die halt dann irgendwie versuchen, aus dem Unterricht zu kommen, indem sie sich bei so einem Erste-Hilfe-Kurs einschreiben. So ist es. Was ist denn live? Ich dachte, es ist die Musical-Gruppe. Ich wusste nicht, was sie hinter den Türen macht. Nicht bei Pepsi, da musste die midi-freie Variante sein. Und seitdem habe ich wirklich so ein Trauma von Glasflaschen, dass die einfach explodieren, wie tickende Zeitbomben. Gab es auch so einen kleinen Pepsi-Pilz, der sich da so gebildet hat? Ein bisschen. Aber wir hatten danach tatsächlich, war die Werbeagentur von Spezi Hart bei uns unterwegs, die Gefahren von Cola, Aufklärungskampagnen. Alle Plakate auf dem Weg zum Schulheim war über Pepsi. Pepsi ist doch gut, nicht alle unsere Flaschen explodieren, hashtag nicht alle unsere Flaschen explodieren.
Ja, und naja, auf jeden Fall hatte ich das, und das ist einfach so ein unangenehmes Gefühl, wenn du weißt, du hast zu Hause eine tickende Zeitbombe und es geht den Bach runter. Also wenn du ein bisschen angespannt bist heute, werden wir hier wirklich fünf Glasflaschen am Tisch stehen, viele davon mit Kohlensäure. Und ich habe so einen Mate-Fluch momentan auf mir. Ich war in Berlin bei dem Age of Empires Event für Rocket Beans TV, schaut euch an, tolle Sache. Da hat mir ein Fan als Unterstützung Mate mitgebracht. Vielen Dank an der Stelle. Welche Mate? Mate Mate, beste Mate. Mate Mate. Und ich wollte sie aber an dem Abend nicht trinken, weil ich früh ins Bett musste. Wow, Rockstar. Und dann dachte ich mir, tue ich die Flasche in die Minibar, um sie zu kühlen, um sie am nächsten Morgen gekühlt mitzunehmen. Das ist das Ding. Gekühlt mitzunehmen, weil es passiert, ich habe sie vergessen. Das heißt, sie steht jetzt noch in der Minibar. Der nächste Gast ist mega verwirrt. Ich habe Reverse Diebstahl betrieben. Ich habe nichts geklaut aus der Minibar. Das denke ich mir immer häufig. Ich habe unerlaubt was reingestellt. Ist das strafbar? Wenn ich im Rewe einfach so einen iPod-Kopfhörer hinlege und dann nimmt die irgendwer und legt die auf die Kasse und dann machen die Piep und dann geht's nicht, dann haben die aber ihr Fächerding vor sich und dann steht da irgendwo iPod-Kopfhörer und dann tippen sie es ein und dann betreibt man es. Ich glaube, ich habe da enorme Verwirrungen dadurch ausgelöst, dass irgendjemand sagt so, ja, was hatten sie aus der Minibar? Ja, die Mate. Wir haben es verwirrungen in der Mate. Hä? Wie, Mate? Und dann betreibt man es. Ich glaube, ich habe da enorme Verwirrungen dadurch ausgelöst, dass irgendjemand sagt so, ja, was hatten Sie das für ein Minibar? Ja, die Marte. Wir haben das Verwirrungen mit Marte. Hä? Wie Marte? Und dann riesen, dann hat sie es auch schon. Ja. Dann riesen Verwirrung. Riesen Eklat. Und dann hat der wiederum was in seinem Podcast zu erzählen. Und dann geht das immer weiter. Also ich glaube, ich habe da was angestoßen. Das ist auch wichtig mal zu sagen, wir sind ein Podcast, der nicht nur für die eigene Stories lebt, sondern wir geben auch.
Weil es ist wichtig, dass wir, also wenn wir die ganze Zeit nur Stories erleben, saugen wir den Humorstandort Deutschland leer. Deswegen brauchen wir langfristig auch Stories für andere Podcasts. Also gebt euch mal, macht mal sowas Verrücktes, schreibt mal irgendwie mit Graffiti euren Namen an die Wand, das ist das Verrücktes, was mir gerade eingefallen ist. Aber es ist wirklich wichtig. Stefan Tietze, Kreativ-Autor.
Ich war hier Stefan.
Das ist so verrückt, das was mir gerade eingefallen ist. Aber es ist wirklich wichtig. Wow, Stefan Tietze, Kreativautor. Ich war hier Stefan. Das ist mir abgefahren, habe ich so noch nirgendwo gesehen. Das ist wichtig, einfach, dass der andere Storys auch noch sät. Wow. Nicht schlecht. Auf jeden Fall, ich habe ein schlechtes Gewissen, zum Glück, gefriert er nicht in der Minibar, aber sie steht jetzt noch in der Minibar und irgendjemand hat Glück. Irgendjemand kommt in dieses Hotelzimmer und hat einfach Glück, dass hier eine kostenlose Marta auf ihn wartet.
Okay, kannst du die Hotelkette verraten?
Nee, das kann ich nicht machen.
Dann kannst du das machen.
Warum sollte man das? Das ist auch häufig so, da sagen dann Prominente oder interessante Persönlichkeiten im Radio sowas wie, das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Und ich bette zu 80 Prozent, könnt ihr das sagen. Du kannst es jetzt auch sagen.
Ja, ich könnte es sagen, ich möchte es aber nicht sagen.
Warum möchtest du es nicht sagen?
Weil ich keine Erwärmung für das Hotel machen möchte, weil sonst hier Ibis anruft. Ibis, ich bin ein Star. Wer ruft jetzt an? Ibis? Nein, ach, Ibis, ach sorry, Entschuldigung. Der Gott, benannt nach dem ägyptischen Gott. Anubis. Imbi. Nee, es gibt auch ... Nee, der Vogel, Ibis. Kiwi, ki ... nee. Iltis meinst du? Ibis ist auch ein Vogel, Ibis. Kiwi.
Iltis meinst du? Ibis ist auch ein Vogel. Daher kommt auch Ibitak. Ibims? Nein. Warum hat Ibis nicht damit Werbung gemacht eigentlich? Ibis, weil man es nicht versteht. Wie willst du das? Ibims, Ibis oder was? Ibis, dein Hotel? Ibis von Hotel her? Das Ibis ist ein Vogel mit dem langen Haken, langen Schnabel.
Ja, guck mal hier. Manchmal sind sie rot, weil sie nur rote Sachen essen. Ist ja so, dass Flamingos nur pink sind, weil die sich von diesen ganzen Bären ernähren, die rot sind und die dann den Stoffwechsel... Ach, das ist wie wenn man sowas wäscht, was Weisses und was Rotes in der Wäsche, dann wird das Weiße Pink. Genau. Auch das, was man isst, man wird nicht direkt zur Farbe, sondern es mischt sich so rein in die Hautfarbe. Deswegen wird man ja auch gelb, wenn man Nierenprobleme hat. Man wird wirklich gelb, hat jetzt nicht unmittelbar mit dem Flamingo, mit dem Phänomen zu tun, aber man wird gelb, wenn man N Nierenprobleme hat. Also falls irgendwen kennt, der ein bisschen gelb ist, Nieren sind
wahrscheinlich die Nieren.
Ja.
Ja, während du
da warst, in dem Hotel,
obwohl du nicht sagen willst, wo es ist,
hatte ich einen Stand-Up-Auftritt mal wieder.
Oh geil. Schon wieder hast du
den Termin von mir verheimlicht.
Ja, ich habe eine Menge Termine.
Häufig mache ich Stand-Up, ohne das zu sagen und ohne euch das immer zu sagen, weil ich erst mal üben will. Und ich habe geübt, und zwar in Krefeld. Und es war wirklich, es war ganz schlimm. Also ich würde sagen, ich bin zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben richtig, richtig, richtig gebombt. Es war knallhart, es war so knallhart, dass ich inzwischen lachen musste, auch auf der Bühne schon, so mich von außen betrachtet habe und lachen musste, weil ich habe dann erst in ratlose Gesichter, dann in wütende Gesichter geschaut. Und es waren auch viele Ältere im Publikum, die angefangen haben, ihre Arme zu verschränken und dann wirklich so mit dem Kopf zu schütteln in mein Gesicht, während ich vorne Gags erzähle. Die wissen noch nicht, wohin meine tolle Anekdote führt, und die haben schon die Arme verschränkt und schütteln mit dem Kopf. Wie groß war das Publikum? Fünfzig, sechzig, sowas. Und jetzt ist es schwierig für mich, da jetzt distanziert darüber zu reden, natürlich, aber wir kennen uns alle. Du kennst mich, die Zuschauer kennen mich so. Das muss man kurz abhaken, es wird schwierig, jetzt sympathisch, darüber zu reden, weil wenn man gebombt hat, ist sich was von der Seele reden zu wollen, nie, kommt nie aus einer coolen Perspektive, nie aus einem coolen Kontext, aber ich versuche das so möglichst möglichst respektiert mal kurz rüberzubringen. Die haben keine Ahnung von Comedy. Die haben absolut keine Ahnung von Comedy. Ne, tatsächlich ist mit dem Nachhinein, natürlich alle die Bomben haben Fehler gemacht. Das gibt gar keine Diskussion. Auch ich habe viele Fehler gemacht. Unter anderem war meine Setlist sehr dark. Also ich habe über sehr dark Themen gesprochen, viel über Tod, bei Hitler habe ich sie komplett verloren. Aber dann muss ich auch sagen, ich finde nach wie vor manche Bits gut.
Ich würde nach wie vor, stehe ich hinter vielen Bits.
Und ich werde die auch wieder machen.
Aber es ist auffällig gewesen, dass das Publikum, sobald man härtere Themen angesprochen hat bereits,
doch keinen Gag gemacht hat, angesprochen hat, schon diese arme Verschränken-Geste gemacht hat.
In der ersten Reihe saß eine Frau, die hat mich angeguckt und hat ihre Augen zugemacht. Als ich angefangen habe, als ich Hitler, als ich seinen Namen in den Mund genommen habe, hat sie die Augen zugemacht und hat sich auf die Schulter ihre Sitznachbarn gelegt. Vielleicht war es im Genuss, vielleicht wollte sie das gewissen. So, ah, jetzt auch hier. Sag doch mal Hitler. Und es war wirklich so unangenehm, diese Abwehrhaltung gegenüber jeglichem darken Gag. Also die haben die Pointe nicht mehr zu Ende hören wollen. Vielleicht war die dann auch scheiße, okay. Aber schon, während man das Setup schon sagt, hat man einfach in so ein, muss man einfach sagen, sehr deutsches Publikum. Danach bekamen Comedien und ich kann mich nicht mehr an den Gag erinnern, ist auch uncool zu sagen, aber die Punchline war, ja Alter, hatte der einen Durchfall, war die Punchline und Leute haben gelacht, Leute haben gerufen, haben geklatscht, sind fast aufgestanden. Man musste den Laden beruhigen, man musste fast eine Unpause einlegen. Und dann dachte ich mir auch, okay. Und wie gesagt, ich bin auch sicherlich schuldfrei. Aber es ist schon, es muss schon gesagt werden, viele gute Gags von Kollegen, ich sag Kollegen, weil das cool ist, aber viele gute Gags von Leuten, die da auch aufgetreten sind, haben nicht funktioniert. Und ich bin mir sicher, weil das war auch wirklich als Ausprobierabend wirklich auch ausgeschildert quasi. Also es war klar, die Leute gehen dahin, um ihr Material zu testen. Und die werden gute Sachen nicht machen jetzt mehr. Und das ist schade. Ja, wenn man es so sieht, wenn man das Publikum entscheidet. Ja, klar, man fragt sich, aber natürlich werden sie es nicht machen, weil viele von denen, das wusste ich auch nicht, viele von denen verdienen ihr Geld mit solchen Auftritten. Und natürlich, wenn die die Wahl haben zwischen einem Gag, der funktioniert hat und einem Gag, der nicht funktioniert hat, werden die Leute, die gerade darauf angewiesen sind, die nicht die Freiheit haben, mal eben irgendwo in Köln aufzutreten, im kleinen Club und so, die eh einen Job haben nebenbei, die werden natürlich unkute Sachen machen. Das hafte Publikum formt letztlich die Comedians. Ja, und dann ist mir erst mal klar geworden, okay, nicht nur die deutschen Comedians sind scheiße, auch das deutsche Publikum ist scheiße, und es ist ein ongoing circle, der sich immer wie so ein Perpetuum mobile in die Scheiße reitet. Ja. Und irgendwer muss man sagen, jetzt machen wir mal einen Cut, einfach, ihr macht, was ihr gut findet, ihr macht, ihr lacht, worüber ihr lachen wollt, und jetzt kommen wir zusammen. Wir machen mal einen Monat lang keine Comedy mehr, und jetzt gucken wir mal, was passiert. Weil das so funktioniert nicht, Leute. Und ich weiß, ich bin nicht in der Lage, das zu entscheiden, gerade, vor allem, weil man nicht darüber reden sollte, wenn man direkt danach das Mikrofon anmacht, aber es ist schon doof. Was hattest du so für Themen? Gut, waren Ein Kind wird geköpft, Hitler, 9-11, Crystal Meth. Okay. War eine Ansage. Es ist mir nicht so richtig aufgefallen, dass es so nach hinten losgehen kann. Vor allem nach dem ersten Thema weißt du ja schon, wie der Auftritt laufen wird. Du hast mit Kindköpfen angefangen, ja, war vielleicht rückblickend und dann merkst du, okay, die gehen da nicht mit und dann guckst du deine Setlist so an, die du so hinten hingelegt hast und es folgt 9-11 und du kommst so und schwitzt und denkst fuck, fuck, fuck, okay, skip, skip, skip okay, easy, ich hab nichts mehr, ciao ja und das war, also ich hab das auch tatsächlich schon lustig wahrgenommen v Auftritt, habe dann irgendwann diese Setlist fotografiert und auch hochgeladen als Gag. Aber dass es so, dass es mir zum Nachteil werden kann, hätte ich nicht angenommen. Und ich glaube, also es fällt schon auf, und das ist auch so befreiend jetzt für mich, weil ab jetzt ist egal, was passiert. Live-Auftritt, Podcast-Ufo, scheißegal, es kann nicht schlimmer laufen. Es kann nicht schlimmer laufen. Naja gut, aber
Podcast Liveauftritt sind vielleicht 90
Minuten. Das stimmt schon.
Wütendes Schweigen. Das stimmt schon, 90 Minuten
lang Hass. Ist dann noch was anderes.
Aber ich fand das wirklich lustig. Also es war wirklich,
es fing wirklich an lustig zu werden.
Und ich glaube, man fragt sich ja
oft, warum Leute dann auch so sehr
selbstbewusst sind und die dann auch wirklich 90 Minuten auftreten
und so. Aber es liegt schon daran, die sind doch oft gebombt. Und dann siehst du doch daraus so ein Selbstbewusstsein, auch aus so einem Fuck-it heraus. Und jetzt habe ich auf jeden Fall Bock, weiterzumachen. Und ich werde manche Themen von denen nochmal machen. Ja, wir haben auch da reinstehen, jetzt ohne zu sagen, dass damit jetzt wir in Verbindung bringen, das schreckliche Publikum, dass die Kommunistiene kaputt macht. Aber wir haben auch einen
Tweet bekommen,
da hat jemand geschrieben, dass ihr euch über Krebs lustig
macht, an uns Podcast-Ufo, dass ihr euch über Krebs
lustig macht, finde ich nicht gut, damit ist
nun wirklich nicht zu spaßen, daran gehen regelmäßig viele
Menschen elendig zugrunde. Ja, aber das habe ich als Scherz verstanden.
Ich habe es erst gelesen und gedacht,
okay, vollidiot, dann dachte ich mir aber,
er
ist halt Scherz gemeint, weil Krebs ja offensichtlich
furchtbar ist. Ja, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass es halt Scherz gemeint ist. Ich glaube, du bist ja eine Stufe
Vielen Dank. dann dachte ich mir aber, er ist als Scherz gemeint, weil Krebs ja offensichtlich furchtbar ist. Ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es als Scherz gemeint ist. Ich glaube, du bist ja eine Stufe zu weit. Und das ist auch mal so interessant, diese, also man macht ja Witze über Krebs und Tabuthemen, weil sie so schlimm sind. Das heißt, dieser Ansatz, hey, ihr dürft euch nicht überkriegslosig machen, das ist eine schreckliche Krankheit, ist, also aus welcher Position heraus argumentiert diese Person? Ich habe es alles verstanden. Ich habe es alles verstanden. Krebs ist so furchtbar, darüber dürft ihr keinen Scherz machen. Weil Krebs so furchtbar ist. Also als Scherz halt. Setup. Wo soll das denn Scherz sein? Ihr könnt doch keine Witze über Krebs machen. Als Setup, Pointe, es ist doch so schrecklich und Leute sterben daran. Aber wo ist das denn eine Pointe? Das ist ja kein Widerspruch. Ich glaube, es ist einfach ein schlechter Witz. Wie weit es cool ist. Es ist schwierig, einen schlechten Witz zu erklären, humortheoretisch. Aber ich bin mir sicher, das ist als Herzgeber. Ich glaube, das ist ernst gemacht. Das ist ja auch, das habe ich schon häufiger gehört, auch das mit irgendwie, keine Witze über Hitler, der war ja schrecklich, hat ja furchtbare Dinge gemacht, was ich so eine merkwürdige Argumentation finde, weil... deswegen macht man ja, aber nur deswegen funktioniert der Witz, also die Person denkt, man würde Witze über Hitler machen, weiß aber nicht, dass Hitler schreckliche Dinge getan hat. Warum würde man dann Witze über, also das ist so ganz merkwürdig. Es ist die alte Diskussion, die Ricky Gervais immer gut auf den Punkt bringt. Viele verwechseln den Inhalt des Gags mit dem Ziel des Gags. Und wenn man mal guckt, und ich finde auch bei vielen jungen Comedians, die dann oft Tabubröche begehen wollen, weil sie halt provozieren, um so halt irgendwie aufzufallen schneller, worin man ja erstmal nicht so viel sagen kann, aber dann ist oft der Ziel des Gags falsch. Und wenn man mal genau guckt, bei allen brisanten Themen, die man so anspricht, die wir versuchen anzusprechen, oder bei guter Arbeit versuchen ansprechen, ist eigentlich immer der Kern des Witzes muss einfach funktionieren und der darf nicht gegen etwas, der geht eigentlich nie gegen das Thema. Ich sag mal, es ist ja einfach eine Meinung, zu sagen, über Krebs sollte man keine Witze machen. Und das ist eine Meinung, die ich ja auch, sag ich mal, nachvollziehen kann, das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung. Und dann, na ja gut, dann ist es halt nicht das richtige Angebot für diese Person.
Ich finde nur die Argumentation so interessant. So dieses, weil es so schrecklich ist, ergibt für mich keinen Sinn. Aber auch da, sag ich mal, vielleicht gehen wir langsam unter mit diesen Themen, obwohl wir jetzt auch nicht diese Themen so stark befeuern.
Sind wir? Nee, wir sind nicht die Themen.
Wir haben über die grosse Pause in der Schule geredet und über Marteflaschen. also wir machen es uns schon ein bisschen leicht man kann nicht gags über marthe machen mal weil marthe so schrecklich ist oder was ihr wollt auf marthe zurück zu kommen zurückkommen ich sehe gerade eine serie und ich unfassbar finde das ich noch nicht vorher entdeckt hat mozart in the jungle ja was eine grossartige serie echt ich habe die erste folge gesehen und Ich find es eine unglaublich tolle Serie. Das ist auch das mit diesem Komponisten, mit diesem Dirigenten. Mit dem Dirigenten, der neu ins New York Symphony Orchestra kommt und anfängt da halt alles auf den Kopf zu stellen. Ich find es thematisch mindblowing. Ich bin großer Fan von Musik, auch großer Fan von Klassik und ich find es toll. Ich find es thematisch toll, es ist gut geschrieben von Jason Schwartzman, unter anderem und dem Sohn von Francis Ford Coppola, Roman Coppola, geschrieben und kritisiert. Oh, das ist eine sehr talentierte Familie. Ja, eine sehr talentierte Familie. Eine fantastische Serie. Und da trinkt der Dirigent, der halt neu kommt, so ein mega-punkiger Typ ist, der Mozart, der trinkt halt immer Mate. aber so originale Mate aus Mexiko. Und der hat immer so ein geiles Gefäß mit so einem grossen metallenen Strohalm. Eingebauten Strohalm, ja. Und das sieht so geil aus. Und man kann nicht dieses Set bestellen. Und ich hab für uns vor, weil wir sind die Mate-Connisseure. Wir sind ja die Oberflächlichen, wir sind ja die, die auf den Zug aufspringen und jetzt die Mate trinken, wir sind ja nicht diese Hardcore-Mate. Aber wir haben schon viel durch. Aber dieses zuckerhaltige Erfrischungsgedrink hat ja jetzt nicht mehr so viel zu tun mit dem... Klar ist auch Tee. Naja, aber das ist so wie Eistee und schwarzer Tee. Das Problem ist, bei Mate kannst du nicht Mate-Tee sagen. Weil du sagst schon mit... Also es klingt unkürzelt. Ja, das stimmt. Deswegen ist man, glaube ich, aus Deutschland geneigt zu sagen, Mathe-Tee. Aber es ist manchmal so leicht, Figuren zu charakterisieren, indem man ihnen einfach so einen Tweak gibt, einfach so was Besonderes. Augenklappe. Es ist so leicht Augenklappe. Captain Hook hat einen Haken. So charakterisieren wir ihn. Okay, und was passiert im Film? Nee, nichts. Der Stichtende Fall. Der Kratz sich und dann, oh nein, er muss eine Augenklappe nehmen.
Es gibt ja dieses berühmte Screenwriter-Buch Save the Cat, wo es genau darum geht, dass man Figuren relativ einfach und schnell charakterisieren kann. Ich glaube, er hat jemanden stottern lassen. Stottern lassen oder halt dieses Save the Cat, dieses titelgebende Phänomen, dass der Held in der ersten Szene eine Katze aus dem Baum rettet und automatisch ist einem der Held sympathisch. So, das ist völlig egal, da muss man nicht viel machen, da muss man kein brillanter Autor sein, sondern man kriegt es hin. Und das ist interessant, weil wenn einem das mal bewusst ist, dieser Mechanismus, sieht man das total oft. Letztes gesehen, Three Billboards Outside Ebbing, Missouri, sehr guter Film, könnt ihr euch anschauen. Sehr langer Titel. Auch da die Hauptfigur in der allerersten Szene kommt in so ein Büro von so einem Werbetypen, in der zweiten Szene, Werbetypen, und da liegt so ein Käfer auf der Fensterbank, der auf dem Rücken liegt und sich nicht mehr bewegen kann und mit den Füssen streichelt. Und die Hauptfigur dreht den so um. Und es hat nichts mit irgendwas in der gesamten Handlung des Films zu tun. Das ist kein guter Save-the-Cat-Moment. Naja, ich weiß nicht, ich finde den Film sehr gut. Es funktioniert auf eine Art, aber es ist schon... Aber du musst ja nicht wegen der Szene gut finden. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Aber es ist schon so ein bisschen, wo man sich denkt, okay, die Figur, die durch den Film sehr ruppig und hart ist und vielleicht nicht direkt irgendwie so sympathisch und likable, aber natürlich macht er natürlich auch eine interessante Figur aus. Aber im Herzen willst du auch eine Person sein, die nachvollziehbare Entscheidungen trifft. Schau dir einen Film an. Okay. Das ist natürlich... Brisant, damit er sich das Finstern nicht. Aber ich finde das so interessant, weil es so einfach so, ja scheiße, die ist schon ein bisschen unsympathisch, oder? Ja. Ja, lass die mal so einen Käfer. Lass die einen Käfer um. Die sehen immer so hilflos aus, wenn sie auf dem Rücken liegen. Ja, falls ihr da irgendeine tiefe Metapher drin seht, könnt ihr die gerne teilen. Aber ich finde es interessant und es ist irgendwie, es fällt einem auf, wenn man das weiß, dass oft Figuren durch so kleine Sachen immer so, ah, likable. Mag ich. Ist ja auch bei Walter White ganz interessant, weil da das Gegenteil der Fall war. Es war Murder the Cat quasi die ganze Zeit, die ganze Serie, weil Leute, den Writern ist aufgefallen, dass das Publikum immer mit Walter White geht, immer. Und dann plötzlich die eigentlich als moralische Instanz vorgesehene Frau einfach mega unsympathisch wurde irgendwann. Alle so, du bist ja genauso schlimm wie Skylar White, es war irgendwann so ein Geflügelt. Sie war unsympathisch einfach für Leute und Leute sind immer mit Walter White gegangen und haben die irgendwann gesagt, ja gut, jetzt nehmen wir ihm auch noch den Geldnied weg. Und wir nehmen ihm auch noch, jetzt hat er Krebs nicht mehr. Und nehmen ihm halt alle Grundlagen weg irgendwann, warum er das mal nur nachvollziehbarweise machen wollte. Und es bleibt nur noch sein, okay, ich break a bat Motiv. Und trotzdem waren Leute immer noch auf seiner Seite. Wohin gegen Vince Gilligan, der Creator der Serie, irgendwann gesagt hat, okay, offensichtlich kann man mit dem Charakter alles machen, wir haben alles versucht, Leute gehen immer noch mit ihm mit, okay, lass ihn wieder Krebs bekommen, scheiß drauf. Ich glaube, wenn du ihn einmal magst, dann ist es glaube ich sehr schwer wiederum, ich glaube, bei Hitler war ähnlich, so weißt du, am Anfang war das ein cooler Typ, der hat ein paar Gags rausgehauen im Wirtshauskeller, man denkt sich, ja cooler Typ, komm, lass es mal da hingehen, ich bin eh nicht so ein politischer Typ. Warum ist Hitler so ein schwieriges Thema, aber wir können auch Nero, sag mal Nero.
Ja, gut, Nero, aber auch Nero irgendwie
Kolosseum
mal unterwegs und dann hat man sich halt mal
so ein paar Löwen mit dem angeguckt
und dann irgendwie so, what,
jetzt brennt die Stadt, naja,
ich finde ihn immer noch ganz cool, man ist
investiert darin. Ich fand so mindblowing
damals, als ich verstanden habe, dass
die Brennsoftware Nero wegen Nero so heißt. Ist ja Wahnsinn. Jetzt geht's los. Icarus hätte uns auch nennen können. Andere coolen Namen für Brennsoftware. Die Top 5 Namen für Brennsoftware. Platz Nummer 5, Prometheus. Platz Nummer 5, Feuer. Platz Nummer 4, Phönix. Platz Nummer 4, Streichholz. Platz Nummer fünf Feuer, Platz Nummer vier Phönix, Platz Nummer vier Streichholz, Platz Nummer drei Feuerzeug, Platz Nummer drei Brennsoftware 24, Platz Nummer zwei Hot, Platz Nummer zwei, hab ich ja auch Hot, hab ich ja auch stehen, Platz Nummer eins. Heiss, heiss, heiss, heiss, heiss. Platz Nummer eins. Nero. Und dann wären wir am Ende gewesen. Ja. Nee, finde ich gut. Da, die Römer. Ich habe was Besonderes vorbereitet heute. Nein. Wow. Ich hole ein kleines Kästchen hervor. Nein, ist nicht dein Ernst! Auf dem draufsteht, nein, ist das geil! Warum hebst du das nicht für bessere Folgen auf? Nein! Und zwar hebe ich hervor ein kleines Paket von 23andme. Und zwar ist das, habe ich entdeckt im neuen Stand-Up-Special von Patton Oswald, wird darüber gesprochen. Alter! Und zwar, 23andMe ist eine Firma, die schicken dir
ein Rohr, da kannst du reinspucken
und dann
und dann werten die
aus und die sagen dir genau,
von welchen Völkern auf der Welt
du abstammst, also woher, wo deine
DNA auf der Welt verteilt ist.
Ich fand das so cool und Patton Oswald hat
gemeint, er stammt,
er hat irgendwie so einen Punkt gehabt in der Mongolei, er hat sich einer angerufen und gefragt, warum Mongolei, und dann meinten die ja ganz direkt, du stammst von Genghis Khan ab. Ja, weil die halbe Welt von Genghis Khan. Aber alle, er hat einfach rumgefögelt. Was? Man kann sagen, ist eine Bitch. Ich glaube auch, dass seine Söhne wieder rumgefögelt haben. Nee, primär Genghis Khan. Aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Anbieter, wie zum Beispiel DNA24.
Nein, es gibt nur diesen einen Anbieter. Und ich habe das mal jetzt mitgebracht, weil ich habe es heute bekommen mit der Post. Kriegst du deine Spucke eigentlich auch zurück? Ja. Wirklich ernsthaft? Nee, kriegst du nicht zurück. Aber was machen die damit? Geben die Kinder in Afrika, die zu wenig Spucke haben. Aber jetzt mal im Ernst, also jetzt mal ganz kurz, ich möchte deine Euphorie kurz bremsen. Es ist ja ein gängiges Geschäftsmodell, dass Leute deine Daten kaufen wollen, also E-Mail-Adressen, Adresse und sowas. Ich meine, DNA ist doch auch wertvoll. Die haben doch da irgendwo eine Datenbank. Lassen wir mal diesen ganzen Sorgen-Scheiz. Die haben doch eine Datenbank mit 10.000 Sätzen DNA, die können das doch verkaufen. Und was wollen die mit einer DNA? Ja, irgendjemand hat bestimmt Interesse, irgendwie NSA oder sowas, dass die deine DNA.
Mit einer DNA.
Ja klar.
Wenn mein Passwort, überall mein DNA. Ups, jetzt wird mir das von hinten. Ja, angenommen, irgendjemand wird umgebracht und da wird DNA gefunden, die keine Datenbank ist, dann fragen die doch bei denen nach, hey, habt ihr ein Match? Einfach mal, um zu fragen. Ist mir aber egal, es ist mir wichtiger, 100 Euro zu bezahlen, um zu wissen, woher ich komme. Und dann tatsächlich... Fehlkauf, ist das eine Fehlkauf? Nee, und ich dachte wirklich, man muss, weil jeder kennt Urintests. So, und dann ist es unangenehm, Urintests sind nicht immer ein bisschen unangenehm, weil du musst meistens nicht so richtig. Dann trinkst du vorher viel, dann musst du sehr viel, und dann weiss man nicht, wie voll soll das jetzt sein, man macht es meistens viel zu voll, die brauchen ja nur zwei Tropfen. Ich dachte, so ähnlich ist es ja auch, man muss einmal reinspucken, es ist nur, wenn ich mit Spucke, und dann wird er gut. Aber jetzt guck mal, das ist ein grosses Reagenzglas. Schau mal, bis wohin man spucken muss. Wow, das sind ja locker zehn Milliliter, oder? Zwanzig? Mir fehlt die richtige Referenz. Aber da muss man richtig reinspucken viel. Und dann dachte ich mir, was wenn jetzt rauskommt, ich bin zu 20 Prozent Bounty-Riegel. Ja, stimmt, das ist ein Problem.
Weil ich gerade einen Bounty-Riegel gäbe.
Cola Light.
Ja, sie kommen zu 15 Prozent aus der Mongolei, zu 20 Prozent von dem Milky Way.
Aber du hast dein Röhrchen jetzt wieder zurückbekommen ohne deine Spucke.
Ach so, warte mal.
Nee, das fängt hier erst an.
Man muss nur hier so viel reinspucken.
Ach so. Da oben ist auch was drin. Im Deckel ist Flüssigkeit drin. What? Ist das doch deine Spucke? Nee. Was ist das? Ich glaube, damit wird das konserviert. Für die Fahrt. Das konserviert doch nicht. Das ist doch... Nee, man muss es so zumachen, zu klappen und dann wird es aufgenommen. Oben ist es immer kleine Silber, durch die Folie. Aber warum funktioniert das denn besser als das Plastik, das drumherum ist? Da muss doch überall Wasser drum sein. Ich glaube, weil es sonst abläuft oder eintrocknet oder sowas. Es ist irgendwas, was es konserviert. Okay, gut. Ich mache das in Ruhe zu Hause. Alles klar. Oder? Aber ich habe da echt Bock drauf. Und dann kann ich, ich schicke das dann ein und dann könnt ihr, ja, dann werde ich euch mitteilen, woher ich abstamme. Aber ganz kurz, ich möchte es ganz kurz, bevor wir die Ergebnisse lesen, ganz kurz verstehen. Was die gemacht haben ist, die haben, die sind in der ganzen Welt rumgereist und haben von ganz vielen verschiedenen Orten DNA-Proben genommen und haben und vergleichen jetzt die DNA, die du ihnen einschickst, prozentual. Wobei, man hat ja auch die DNA vom vom ötzi hat ja auch die dna von urvölkern der mayas und so die auch oder ägypter ich schätze einfach dass sie dass die stämme nehmen so was immer bei denen gleich war und sowas und werden das dann abgleichen mit der dna die man selber mitbringt und dann werden die sagen da oder aber wo haben die die ganze Also die müssen doch dann von, also ich meine, wenn du jetzt einfach mal einen Munker auslösen musst, der ist ja nicht repräsentativ. Ja, und dann hat er noch ein Chromosom weniger und dann hat er irgendwann sicher, ja gut. Und auch der ist nicht zu wenig Bounty, also da schleicht sich auch was irgendwie in die Allelen ein. Deswegen ist es ja auch schwierig. Spezieller Humor. Aber ... Ja, oder gibt's, oder kann man in den DNA selbst lesen, wo man herkommt, oder ist einfach nur ein Vergleich mit den Leuten, wo sie jetzt wohnen? Ich glaube, ja, ich glaube, die wissen jetzt, die haben jetzt sehr viel DNA-Proben und die sagen, dein Stamm ist ähnlich wie der von der Ying-Yang in Japan und deswegen ist deine DNA auch hier zu so einem gewissen Prozentsatz. dann gibt es ein Kuchendiagramm und da ist ein bisschen Japan, weil Yang Yang genau die gleichen DNA-Stammateien. Da müsste bei dir doch rauskommen einfach nur Deutschland. Wahrscheinlich ist ein grosser, ich meine die Leute, die jetzt in Deutschland wohnen und sage, da ist ein grosser, da ist ein grosser Punkt auf Deutschland. Ich verstehe es nicht, weil wenn die die aktuelle DNA nehmen, dann ist deine aktuelle DNA auch die, die jetzt keine Deutschland ist. Das System hat Schwächen, wir sind noch in der Beta-Phase. Es ist vor allem interessant für Leute, die in den USA leben, weil die ja weniger nachvollziehen können, woher ihre Völker kommen. Ja, aber du nimmst doch auch Proben aus den USA, oder nicht? Ja, ja, ja. Ich lese mich noch einmal genau ein, würde ich sagen. Ich war nur so gehuckt, allein, ich habe auch schon mal sowas gemacht, so Ahnenforschung, ich finde das einfach wahnsinnig spannend, weil ich bin auch sehr gross. Alles Nazis, oder? Ja, alles Nazis. Ich bin auch sehr gross, ich will auch wissen, woher habe ich diese Größe. Stamm ich vielleicht von einem Yeti ab? Man weiß es nicht genau. Ich finde das wahnsinnig spannend. Vielleicht geht es nach hinten los. Hast du denn schon reingeschaut oder ist es jetzt wirklich das erste Mal? Nee, ich hab noch nicht reingeschaut. Hast du denn die Ergebnisse schon? Nee, wie gesagt, die kommen ja noch. Ich muss erst mal reinspucken. So, Alter, ich dachte jetzt die ganze Zeit, wir machen spannend und jetzt kommen gleich die Ergebnisse. Nein, das ist doch erst der Prolog. Ich hab das gerade erst bekommen. Oh Mann, jetzt hab ich mich so gefreut, ich hab schon so viele Mongolenwitze auf Lager. Ja, da musst du wohl noch, du musst auf Folge 127 fahren. Muss noch mal reinhören. Ach ja, komm, Florian, wir machen noch andere tolle Themen heute. Ich muss erst mal da hinschicken. Das war nur die Prolog-Folge. Ja, okay. Ich habe mich auch gefragt. Aber willst du eine Schätzung abgeben? Ja, also ich glaube, Ägypten. Ich glaube, ich stamme aus Ägypten ab, primär. Dem aktuellen Ägypten oder dem antiken Ägypten oder was? Da muss ich mich erstmal einlesen. Jetzt hör auf einmal diese Folgen. Ich dachte, das wäre eine gute Idee. Wenn die uns schon Sponsoren davon ab, dann müssen wir doch genauer erklären, was es denn ist. Wir haben den Namen falsch ausgesprochen, die wissen, dass wir das nicht können zum Sponsoren. Jetzt ist da ein Fussel rein. Jetzt komme ich wahrscheinlich, bin ich zur Hälfte drin. Sorry, ich bin so dumm, du musst es erst noch abschicken, oder was? Jesus Christ! Mein Auge zuckt. Aber warum hast du, als ich gefragt habe ... Als du diese Dummheit vor dir gegeben hast, fängt mein Auge an zu zucken. Mein Gehirn kann das nicht wahrnehmen. Aber warum, als ich gefragt habe, oh, die haben dir das wieder zurückgeschickt, warum hast du denn nicht gesagt, nein, ich hab's noch nicht abgeschickt? Nee, das hab ich nicht gehört. Die haben mir was geschickt, hab ich auch gefragt, warum du das genau so sagst, warum du das nochmal betonst. Aber man kriegt erst sein Reinspuck-Set, das hab ich gerade hier noch. Hier, Florentin, muss ich erst hineinspucken und dann schick ich ab. Okay. Also, wenn ihr aus der Zukunft direkt zur Folge 127, da haben wir das schon aufgelöst und haben Heidenspucken. Und dann schicke ich es ab. Okay. Also, wenn ihr aus der Zukunft
direkt zur Folge 127,
da haben wir das schon aufgelöst und haben Heidenspaß damit.
Gerade sind wir noch ein bisschen verwirrt, genau wie das funktioniert.
Oder in der Live-Show.
Ja, oder in der Live-Show. Holt euch noch Tickets.
Gibt's nicht mehr. Wow.
Hast du eine Schätzung?
Ägypten, sagst du? Ja, ich sag Ägypten.
Wie viel Prozent?
89. Wahnsinnig ägyptisch, glaube ich,? Ja, ich sag Ägypten. Wie viel Prozent?
89.
Wahnsinnig ägyptisch, glaube ich, bin ich veranlagt.
Nee, ich fühle mich auch so.
Also, ich fühle mich da so hingezogen.
Die Götter finde ich alle spannend.
Dieser Kopfschmuck, den finde ich wahnsinnig ästhetisch.
Ich denke mir, also wenn ich die Wahl hätte,
jetzt nochmal so eine Hardcore-Religion, mich reinzufuchsen,
würde ich wahrscheinlich Ägypten nehmen.
Ja, die alte ägyptische ... Das war übrigens auch ein Bit, den ich gemacht habe, der nicht ankam.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe Angst vor dem Tod,
Und um mich reinzufuchsen, würde ich wahrscheinlich Ägypten nehmen. Ja, die alte ägyptische ... Das war übrigens auch ein Bit, den ich gemacht habe, der nicht ankam.
aber ich habe nicht Angst vor dem Tod an sich,
ich habe Angst, dass eine Religion Recht hatte.
Aber wenn wir eine Religion Recht hatten, haben wir alle ein Riesenproblem.
Außer Christen kann man nur noch beichten halt,
und das ist einigermaßen cool alles danach.
Aber was wäre ein wahnsinniges Problem,
wenn wir plötzlich da oben ankommen und dann stellt sich raus, dass so ein kleines ägyptisches Dorf Recht hatte. Was macht man dann? Nach so einem wahnsinnigen Problemen. Dann kam ich Gags abgefeuert und wow und Leute haben gebuht. Aber ich finde das wirklich eine wahnsinnig lustige Vorstellung. Wenn man einfach, die hatten halt Recht, die mit den grossen, die mit den Tierköpfen, die hatten Recht. Es ist so ein bisschen, ich glaube, wenn ich tot wäre und dann irgendwo aufwarte, denke ich mir, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr schlecht. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit statistisch gesehen ist extrem. Als Christ hast du den Vorteil, du kannst sagen, kann ich doch kurz beichten, alles. Selbst als Christ bin ich bei 15 Prozent so, aber ich bin zumindest getauft so. Ja, wir haben schon mal gebetet, jeder betet so.
Aber bitte lass mich niemanden neben mich setzen bei der U-Bahn.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut ankommt.
Lass Werder Bremen gewinnen, bitte.
Jeder betet mal kurz.
Aber ich meine so,
du hast selten an Anubis,
du hast selten gesagt,
hey Anubis, ganz kurz,
wenn Deutschland wieder eine Goldmedaille gewinnen könnte.
Es gab doch diese zwei ägyptischen Götter, die zusammengefasst wurden. Hä? Ist das jetzt Schlagzeile für dich? Hä? Was? Wer wurde zusammengefasst? Es gab zwei Religionen, die man hat gesagt, komm, wir sind so ähnlich, fassen wir es zusammen. Nee, es gab zwei egyptische Götter, die zusammengebaut wurden einfach so. Wie zusammengebaut wurden? Wie zusammengebaut wurden? Naja, da gab es dann halt irgendwie keine Ahnung, Ram und Sees und dann hat man gesagt, das ist so verwirrend, ey, lassen Sie sie einfach zusammenfassen und dann so, ja passt schon, wir kürzen das so ein bisschen zusammen. Wir haben 80 Götter, warum sagen die bei zwei, nee, das reicht, das ist jetzt die Grenze, bei 81 ist Schluss.
Ich kann mir 81 Namen gut merken, 82, nope, fassen wir zusammen.
Wie googelt man das denn, ey, das ist doch scheiße.
Vor allem man muss auch sagen, dass die ägyptischen Götter sind auch cool, also die sind so ein bisschen so,
ich finde, hier ist ja wie Alexander Dobrindt ist ja Chef von Verkehr und von Internet und der digitale Minister, wo man so gesagt hat, komm, das kriegst du jetzt auch noch, Internet kriegst du jetzt auch noch Verkehrsminister. So umdrauf einfach. Ja genau, und bei den Göttern ist auch so ein bisschen, das ist die Göttin der Liebe und des Volleyballs. Ja, ich meine, bis zu einem gewissen Punkt, glaube ich, kann man die schon noch patchen, diese Götter. Ich meine, du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen, es gibt einen Gott fürs Internet oder so, aber es gibt irgendwie so einen Gott für Handwerk. Oder ist nicht sogar Hermes auch so ein Postgott? Der bringt die Briefe? Der Götterbote. Ja. Und was noch? Der hat die Post. Nee, das ist sein Ministerium. Ja, und der hat, glaube ich, so, nee, und auch der Interpretation und der Auslegung. Deswegen sagt man Hermeneutik. Post und Pilze, komm. Forstwirtschaft, fuck it, ist egal. Aber ich sag mal, Post war noch ein technologischer Fortschritt, den man noch integriert hat in die Götterwelt, zu sagen, ja, Post ist eine super Sache. Aber wer ist der Internetgott? Es gibt keinen Internetgott, es gibt hier für Scrabble oder hier für dieses, wie heißt das, wo man auf dem Boden so rumkriecht? Twister. Twister, kein Gott dafür. Aber bestimmt irgendwo in den Ägyptischen haben die irgendwas.
Mann, ich finde das jetzt nicht.
Das ist auch, on the fly recherchieren ist schwierig.
Schreibt einmal auf die Tour, wo auch irgendwas zum Nachschlagen.
Nachschlagewerk.
So ein Fact-Checker.
Wo auch ein Nachschlagewerk.
Aber der hieß irgendwie so, zwei Götter mit jeweils einer Silbe wurden zusammengelegt
zu einem Gott mit zwei Silben.
Ramses kann er sein.
Ramses ist ja ein Pharao. Genau. Pharao. Agamemnon. Tut endlich. Kommt Phara von Pharao? Ja. Lass mal weiter. Also mein Ägypten-Warnlicht ist gerade angegangen, weil wir haben zu oft zu lange über Ägypten gesprochen. Leute verlassen uns. Ich glaube, das Spannendste, was man machen kann, ist in Ägypten die Pyramiden sich anzuschauen. Wow! Lass mich das präzisieren. Ein Satz, wo du in viele Richtungen abbiegen hättest können, dass du dich dafür entschieden hast, das war nicht abzusehen. Ich glaube, das Beste, was du machen kannst, ist in Paris
dir den Eiffeltürm anzuschauen.
Das waren die Reisetipps.
In Ägypten, so eine Reisegruppe
in die Pyramiden,
locker 30% Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Weil in jeder Verschwörungstheoretik
hast du immer die Pyramiden
mit, das waren
eigentlich Kraftwerke, die haben schon Strom
erzeugt, die Aliens haben das gebaut und für normale Menschen ist eine Pyramide nicht so unfassbar. Das ist eine Form. Die haben eine Form gebaut. Ja, die haben halt Steine aufgebaut, das kann mein dreijähriges Kind auch. Gut, das waren halt viele, also groß, easy. Aber verschwünsfähig, das heißt, du gehst da als Tourist rein und hast dann irgendwie so ganz so weirde Typen, die irgendwie dann so mit so Geigerzählern durch die Gegend laufen und sagen so, so, jetzt schauen wir uns das Kraftwerk an, Renate, jetzt gehen wir rein, jetzt gucken wir, wo die Reaktoren sind, ich sagte, ich hatte recht und machen Fotos von einem. Nur geile Leute. Und der Guide einfach so, so. Nein, das ist ein Grabmal. Das ist einfach. Das ist das Grabmal. Und im Hintergrund rempelt die sich so an und so, Grabmal. Hast du dir ausgedacht? Hast du auswendig gelernt? Ja, ich hab ausgedacht. Und wo ist die Schatzkammer, ja, die Schatzkammer, da gibt es keinen Zutritt dafür, das ist leider unter Urheberrecht, also unter Gedenkmalschutz und so und alle immer so. Aha, und wo sind die Aliens? Ja, wie ich am Anfang gesagt habe, Aliens haben das nicht gebaut, nett, aber ich glaube, der schlechteste Job, den du haben kannst, ist ein Tourguide in den Pyramiden. Aber du hast halt auch leider Touristen dazu, weil die Strände ringsherum cool sind. Ja, Rentner, Verschwörungstheoretiker und Touristen, die schlimmsten drei Gruppen, die es gibt. Wo du nur Verschwörungstheoretiker hast, sind in Nevada, Büste Nevada, Roswell zum Beispiel, wo Area 51 steht und auch der Absturzort ist von diesem UFO angeblich in Roswell. Da würde ich gerne mal hin. Ich glaube, der zweitschlechteste Job, Tourguide in Area 52. So, wo keine Sau hinkommt. Einfach so, ja, wir haben hier Flugzeughangas und Drohnenprogramm ist hier auch recht stark. Sind Sie sicher, dass Sie nicht zu Area 51 wollen? Sie sind der einzige Tourist. Ich glaube, die schlechten Security Guards, einfach Area 52, komm. Wollen Sie wirklich ein Ticket kaufen, Area 52? Sind Sie sich sicher? Und dann tut einem der Security Guide leid und sagt so, ja, würde ich gerne. Wirklich? Wirklich? Sie wollen die Landebahn sehen? Aber nur kurz. Sie wollen den Atombunker sehen? Wie weit ist denn Area 51 weg? Nur mal so kurz, nur so rein zeitlich. Fünf Minuten ist direkt nebenan. Okay, komm dann, wollen wir es mal? Komm dann. Okay, okay, okay, okay, wow, ich habe schon seit drei Jahren. Also hier, das ist die Militärbasis, also da dürfen Sie nicht rein, das ist alles streng geheim, aber da hinten können Sie ja mal gucken, ob Sie die Landebahn sehen. Gibt es denn eine Cafeteria oder? Ne, wie gesagt, alles bei 51. Und da hinten ist ein kleiner Merchandiseladen mit dem I Survived Area 52. Wir wollen Sie auch gar nicht mehr Arbeit Arbeit abhalten. Ich meine, ist auch streng geheim. Sie dürfen uns gar nicht mehr viel teilen. Tatsächlich überhaupt nicht geheim, nur nicht eine Gebäude. 52, wir haben nichts zu verbergen. Okay, auf drei. Wie viele Areas gibt es denn eigentlich? Soll man die Frage, ist es erlaubt, die Frage zu stellen? Oder ist das wegen Bundesstaaten? Es gibt ja 50 Bundesstaaten. Ist deswegen Area 51? Ne. Ach so, wie der siebzehnte Spieler. Wie Mallorca, der siebzehnte Bundesland. Ne, der zwölfte Spieler ist der Fan. Der zwölfte Mann. Der zwölfte Mann. Der zwölfte Spieler. Ja, oder oder der zwölfte Protagonist. Du bist so intellektuell für Sport. Apropos, ey, Olympia. Olympia, mein Lieblingssport, mein Lieblingssportereignis. Muss man sagen. Aber es sind ja so ein bisschen die... Also es ist ja so, für mich noch zwei Paralympics, die Winter-Olympiade. Ich finde die fast noch besser, weil du hast Curling dabei, du hast, Leute rutschen
in Schlitten einfach
den Bobkanal runter, man fragt sich,
es heißt Bobkanal, ihr benutzt,
eure Sportart ist schon falsch.
Ja, vor allem Winterspiele sind für mich so,
ah, okay, ihr seid die zehn Leute,
die irgendwie noch Schnee in ihrem Land haben,
cool, kommt mal her, okay, wer von euch kann am weitesten
springen im Snowboard, ah, okay, gut,
einer aus Island, einer aus Kamerun.
Und dann kommt jemand aus Kenia rein und
wird letzter und alle freuen sich,
Vielen Dank. Cool, kommt mal her. Okay, wer von euch kann am weitesten springen im Snowboard? Ah, okay, gut, einer aus Island, einer aus Kamerun. Und dann kommt jemand aus Kenia rein und wird letzter und alle freuen sich, weil er zumindest dabei gewesen ist. Es gibt ja keinen Nachwuchs für Wintersportarten, es gibt keinen Nachwuchs, das heißt, wir können jetzt anfangen, das abzubauen. Wir können jetzt anfangen, die ganze Lift abzubauen, in den 20 Jahren gibt es das nicht mehr. Und mal ganz unter uns dabei sein ist auch nicht wirklich alles. Ist nicht wirklich alles. Es ist nicht mal die Hälfte. Ey, da gehört schon noch eine Menge dazu. Wirklich nicht mal die Hälfte. Vor allem dann kam es zu der Situation, dass Curling gegeneinander gespielt wurde und es ist ja schon Teil so ein bisschen Hobby eigentlich. Das ist ja nicht wirklich die Sportart, mit der die Geld fährt. Es bleibt halt dieser Hobbyaspekt, der ist ganz cool, vor allem beim Curling, wo man sich fragt, ist das wirklich das, wollt ihr das leben, wollt ihr das machen, ist ein bisschen lächerlich. Vor allem, es gab doch diesen einen, ich glaube, russischen Sportler war das, wo jetzt wieder so ein Doping-Skandal ist und der war Curler, wo ich auch so, ja okay, nicht cool, dass er dopt, aber Curling. Aber wollen wir da nicht einfach sagen, lass ihm doch seine Medaille, lass ihm doch. Also ich kann verstehen, to the France, einfach massive Leistung, einfach dein Körper. Hast du die Beine danach gesehen, nur eine große Ade. Ja, dein Körper muss einfach ballern, wie es geht, aber Curling, so filigran irgendwie das Eis. Ich meine, das kann jeder, jeder, der es dreimal macht, kann den so weit nach hinten stoßen. Aber das müssen wir mal herausfinden, worin der gedopt hat, was er für ein Mittel genommen hat. Also ich sie es dann so einfach Leistungssteigern, wo man sich denkt so, okay, das ist mir schon klar. Oder er hat einen besseren Besen genommen, er hat einen Staubsauger genommen. Ja. Oder er hat so einen Stein genommen, der hinten explodiert und die anderen Steine wegschießt. Ja, das kann sein. Oder so einen ferngesteuerten, wo dann irgendwie der Trainer irgendwie dann so zusammengekaut, hinten steht mit so einer Fernbedienung und dann fährt er so und dann so, Drohne.ne und man sieht so, wow, wer hat das denn gemacht? Ich hab's crazy angedreht, ich hab's angedreht so. Nee, nee, angedreht, angedreht, angedreht, angedreht. Ist doch gedobt. Der Stein ist doch gedobt. Nein, nein. Oder so ein Magnet von, wer, wer kontrolliert den Keller von diesen Waren, dass du mit starkem Magneten unten an die Decke und die Erbückelst, von wem, von wem,
zeig ihn mir, und wie viel
Geld kostet es dir zu bestechen?
Hat das Curling was von so einem Minigame?
Also es ist wie,
wenn du ein Spiel spielst, aber das ist nicht ein richtiges Spiel,
sondern du musst halt erst das Tutorial
machen. Ja, oder so eine Lagepause,
während das eigentliche Spiel lädt, kann man Curling spielen.
Zeig Curling, solange bis Ladung nicht anfängt.
Und jedenfalls haben dann
es spielen dann oft Ehepaare zusammen.
Die sind das Team. So die Frau muss putzen.
Wird nicht oft so, dass die Frau
die Frau putzt oder der Mann, ist eigentlich egal.
Manchmal die Frau muss man sagen.
Das ist schon so fragwürdig. Und der Mann
stösst an und macht das Philipp. Jeder muss mal putzen,
oder? Es gibt da so einen Putzplan.
Ob da ein Putzplan herrscht. Vor allem, ich finde, das Eis ist schon sehr sauber. Ja, muss man auch mal sagen. Also die Leute, die professionelles Eis reinigen, die dann mit diesen Gefährten drüberfahren, die denken sich auch so, äh, hallo, soll ich jetzt nochmal drüberfahren oder soll man es lassen an der Stelle? Nach dem Eishockey-Spiel werden auch einfach gecurlt direkt. Ja, ja. Naja, und dann hatten die wohl so einen Ehistreit,
die Curler. Ah, nein.
Und dann haben die die noch relativ offen ausgetragen.
Und Curling besteht ja zu, sagen wir mal,
zu zehn Prozent aus Wischen und zu neun Prozent
aus Anschreien. Bob, mach das schneller,
mach das schneller! Dann gab es dann dieses russische Pärchen,
was halt einen Ehistreit hatte. Und was
dann halt, hat dann der Kommentator auch so
ganz offen einfach thematisiert. Okay, sehr
indiskret, aber sag ruhig weiter.
Irgendwie interessiert es mich auch.
Und dann hat halt die Frau das Ding geschoben und hat den Mann halt angeschrien.
Und man denkt so, ist das, das wird auch gecurlt oder wird gerade der Ehe-Streit einfach öffentlich auf der Weltbühne ausgetragen?
Oh, der Wurf sieht gut aus. Jetzt kommt der Vorwurf, sich nochmal mit Nadja getroffen zu haben.
Was war da eigentlich los?
Sie ruft nochmal an, er rollt mit den Augen und sagt, da war nichts, da war nichts, Schatz, der Stein während dessen weiter... Jetzt lass mich wie Köln doch gerade. Aber es scheint beliebt zu sein in Russland, oder? Wenn die viel Eis haben? Wenn die dopen dabei vor allem. Vor allem dieser Leistungsdruck, der offensichtlich da herrscht beim Köln, dass man meint, dopen zu müssen, dass man so unter Druck steht, dass man sagt, weißt du was, eins will ich unbedingt, um sogar illegal dafür Substanzen einzunehmen. Ich will Curling-Olympiasieger werden. Hat er gewonnen noch? Ja, ich glaube schon. Und es ist dann so, muss man dann die Goldmedaille zurückgeben oder kriegt dann der Zweite die Erste und der Zweite die Dritte und der Dritte die Vierte und dann musst du den immer zu Hause anrufen und so. Vor allem hat dieser Medaillenspiegel ja auch einfach gar keinen Zweck. Also er zeigt an, klar, welche Mannschaft am meisten Medaillen hat, aber erst mal, du kannst dich nicht vergleichen, weil Kamerun kommt da mit einem Mann an, der muss auch gleichzeitig die Fahne tragen die ganze Zeit und macht dann halt im Schlitten mit, weil er mal Schlitten gefahren ist, im Winterurlaub. Und dann gibt es ja immer das deutsche Dorf, gibt es dann auch das kenianische Dorf, wo er dann ist, weiss man nicht genau. Und dann hängt er halt ab und dann, natürlich können die keine, warum vergleicht man die Länder? Weil Deutschland hat jetzt mittlerweile 40 Medaillen oder sowas. Ja, vor allem, man muss ja auch mal sagen, es ist ja auch 500 Menschen unterschiedlich schwer, Goldmedaillen zu gewinnen in manchen Disziplinen. Manche kriegst du hinterhergeworfen und bei anderen musst du da wirklich dein ganzes Leben trainieren oder so. Curling musst du dopen. Ja, ich glaube, es gibt halt so eine Sportart, die du halt mal nebenbei irgendwie, wie gesagt, im Verein machst und dann, oh, du hast Talent, willst du hinfahren? Ja, okay. Und dann holst du halt die Goldene.
Nee, nächste Woche passt mir nicht, da ist doch Job und der Frank hat schon Urlaub genommen. Ach so. Wenn ich da jetzt auch Urlaub nehme, ist die ganze IT-Abteilung leer. Paul und Karen, habt ihr Lust?
Ja, so läuft es so. Aber ich habe heute gelesen, dass Norwegen ist ja auf Platz eins im Medaillenspiegel, vor Deutschland noch. Das darf auch nicht der Fall sein, da hat die Bildzeit direkt registriert und gesagt, nein, da ist irgendwas faul, die haben mehr Medaillen als wir und haben recherchiert.
Und tatsächlich haben die am meisten Medikamente legal importiert bekommen in das Dorf. Und zwar irgendwie so 60.000, ja keine Ahnung, also nicht für Fakten, eben für Faktenfeste bei uns, aber sehr viel Asthma-Spray haben die bekommen. Weil angeblich alle deren Langläufer, die alle gewonnen haben, haben Asthma. Dann nehmen die halt Asthma-Spray, die Lungen werden erweitert, bessere Sauerstoffaufnahme und so fürs Blut und so. Aber muss man eigentlich beweisen, dass man Asthma hat? Doch, genau. Du musst halt einen ärztlichen Attest vorlegen, dass du Asthma hast. Ja, gut, okay. Und dann kannst du halt Asthma nehmen, bis du umfällst, ein bisschen neuer Grenze. Und dann darfst du halt auf jeden Fall mit offensichtlichem Mittel im Intus fahren, wo du halt mehr Sauerstoff und Blutabmärmigkeit, sondern auch leistungsfähiger bist. Das heißt, die Asthmatiker, die ihr Leben lang gemobbt wurden, plötzlich, wenn sie Langläufer werden, sagen sie, tja Leute, jetzt ziehe ich an euch allen vorbei. Es ist vor allem, und irgendwie haben fünf Prozent der Menschheit haben Asthma, aber die Top 20 der Welt im Langlauf haben alle Asthma, haben alle Asthma, das ist schon auffällig. Das ist schon verrückt. Aber die haben kein Asthma. Aber warum nehmen dann nicht alle Asthma-Spray? Weil es nicht erlaubt ist. Das ist ja für Basketball auch gut, wenn die Lungen erweitert sind. Ja, ist halt nicht erlaubt. Ja, aber für Langlauf dann schon, oder was? Nee, nur weil die Asthma haben. Ja gut, aber kann man sich dann so ein Attest nicht faken? Yeah, das glaube ich ja. Ich unterstelle dir jetzt gerade einfach knallendes Doping. Was, haben Sie Husten? Nee, Asthma. Wollen Sie das Asthma-Spray verschicken? Ja. Langläufer? Ja. Jetzt würde es mal eine Stöcke halten. Langläufer einfach so, sorry, muss man auch mal sagen, so, Bergunterfahren macht Spaß, das ist einfach wie wenn du dein Auto schiebst. Wenn du dein Auto selbst über Nürnberg trinkst. Du benutzt hier falsch. Dafür ist es nicht gedacht, einfach. Das ist wie wenn du so einen Wettlauf im Fahrrad schieben, neben dem Fahrrad herlaufen und dann so ganz schnell tippeln. So einfach so, nein, so funktioniert es nicht. Die Sportart gehen ja auch so, auch weird ist, so geht man ja auch nicht. Bist du denn im Langlauf wirklich schneller, als wenn du läufst? Nein, weiß ich nicht. Doch, die Trainer rennen ja manchmal hinterher. Die Trainer dürfen nur auf die Strecke laufen und dürfen die Leute beschimpfen und anfeuern und so ein Kram. Und geben denen dann Trinkflaschen und so ein Kram. Manche auch einfach Weissbier trinken, wo man sich auch fragt, okay, jetzt ist alles egal oder was. Geht's noch um was, wo man auch zwischendurch so einen Sportler anhält? Ist es noch Spielstopp oder können wir ... Es geht um was. Und Biathlon, sorry, Langlauf und Schießen? Und sind die dann auch gut in Langlauf? Warum machen Langläufer nicht Biathlon gibt's da irgendwann und Skispringer? Gibt's ja auch diese neudische Kombination, das ist ja Biathlon und Skispringen und Langlauf. Ja, meine Cousine zum Beispiel war erfolgreiche Biathletin und die hat auch gesagt, sie interessiert Schießen überhaupt nicht, sie interessiert sich nur für Langlauf, aber im Biathlon gibt's... Warum machst du nicht Langlauf? Aber beim Biathlon gibt's einfach höhere Preisgelder, mehr Werbedeals und sowas. Und die hat dann halt einfach schießen gelehrt und einfach stupide runtergeübt, so dass sie es halt hinkriegt, jetzt nicht irgendwie hundert Strafrunden fahren zu müssen. Aber das war, da habe ich auch immer mir gedacht, Mensch, wow. Ich habe mir gedacht so, wow, ich als Elfjähriger habe da relativ wenige Meinungen dazu. Ich habe keine Meinungieten. Kann ich bitte wieder weiter spielen gehen? Aber Biathlon ist Ski-Langlauf und Skischießen. Triathlon ist Schwimmen, Fahrradfahren und Curling. Es ist einfach wie so eine Minispiel-Kollektion. Es hat so ein bisschen so, es reicht doch nicht, wir müssen noch mal was machen. Komm, das ist wie eine Kurzgeschichte. Alle hassen Kurzgeschichten, aber so ein Kurzgeschichtenband liest man durch zwei, drei, um dann zu merken, eigentlich hasse ich Kurzgeschichten. Es ist auch so entstanden, man hat ein Publikum gehabt in der Stadt, hat gesagt, komm, jetzt ist gerade die eine Sportart, die wir haben, hat gerade Pause. Zeig denen was anderes. Lass die Stäbe weit werfen oder so. Komm, zeig denen das. Und Leute waren begeistert. Vor allem, ganz kurz, wenn du schon eine Winter-Olympiade machst, warum zur Hölle... Ist keine Schneeballschlacht, oder? Keine Schneeballschlacht, ich wollte es gerade sagen. Warum macht man nicht die Schneeballschlacht? Oder Schneemann bauen. Wer den größten Schneemann baut? Schneeballschlacht ich gut. Schneeballschlag ist Lawine überleben. Ja, sehr gut. Entfesseln. 15 Minuten hat man Zeit, wenn man von der Lawine überschüttet wurde. Genau. Bis man tot ist. Ja. So. Und Schneeballschlag wird auch richtig, also ich meine, da muss man sich natürlich über die Regeln Gedanken machen und so, Ist halt so ein bisschen so wie die Lasertag, was halt super lame ist und so. Aber warum an sich ... Warum jetzt auf Lasertag rum? Echt was? Schliesslich bin ich so ein Lasertag-Freund. Ich habe es aber auch nie gemacht. Ja, ne? Wollen wir mal Lasertag gehen? Auf gar keinen Fall. Und wir nehmen so eine Kamera mit unseren zwei Reporter-Mikrofonen und machen so einen unangenehmen Beitrag. So einen alten, so einen Nineties-Harald-Schmidt-Show-Beitrag. Ja, so ein Stefan in Gefahr. Ja, Stefan in Gefahr. Heute sind wir hier in der Lasertack-Halle in Köln-Ernfeld. Schau mal hier rein. Dann immer auch so unangenehm zwischengeschüttete Memes und sowas. Das machen wir mal. Ja, das passt gar nicht zu uns. Abonniert weiterhin das YouTube-Ufo 2, auf dem ihr tolle Videos bekommen könnt und wir in Gefahr sind. Toll. Skifahren hat auch schon immer Spaß gemacht. Naja, ich wollte morgen Brötchen kaufen und dann ist mir was passiert, was mir häufiger passiert. Also du wirst nicht relaten können, aber alle Brillenträger werden relaten können. Wenn man aus der Kälte in warme Räume kommt, beschlagen die Brillen und man sieht aus wie der Typ aus Sin City? Der Typ aus Sin City, wie Elijah Wood. Man sieht aus wie eine fucking, wie eine Massenmörder-Comic-Buchfigur. Und es ist einfach unangenehm. Und es versaute den ganzen Tag, es versaute dein Standing. Du kommst in den Raum, das ist wirklich sprichwörtlich das Erste, was man macht. Du kommst in den Raum rein und du bist direkt ein Freak. Deine Brillen beschlagen und so langsam, Leute gucken dir in die Augen und langsam, wird das Glas so milchig und man sieht einfach aus wie, man kenne es ja bei Blinden. Ja. Wenn man blinde, man unangenehm in die Augen guckt, ganz unangenehm diese milchigen Augen. Und vor allem, da musst du improvisieren, und was hätten Sie gerne? Ich nehme eine Apfeltasche. Ich habe das Angebot nicht gesehen, aber ich gehe all in, ich nehme eine Apfeltasche. Und ich wollte echt, es war ein neuer Bäcker heute mal.
Neuer Bäcker wie neuer Bäcker?
Ich bin woanders ausgestiegen, weil ich das 23andMe Setup holen musste auf der Post.
Und da war halt ein Bäcker und da wollte ich ihn ausprobieren und dann musste ich die Brille abnehmen.
Holy shit, Alter!
Aus so einem Reflex heraus, aber dann siehst du ja auch nichts.
Ja.
Es ist halt mega unangenehm.
Ich habe den Bäcker-Bediener angesehen, er wollte mich normal behandeln wie ein normaler Mensch. Es war gezwungen. Er hat mich anders wahrgenommen. Manchmal so mit Bedienungen, manchmal klickt es und manchmal nicht. Manchmal hat man eine Ebene, manchmal hat man einfach keine Ebene. Ja, und genau so war es. Und es ist auch manchmal, wenn man abends in eine Kneipe kommt oder in eine Bar oder in einen Club, dann hast du direkt die beschlagenen Augen und alle potenziellen Sexualpartner sind sofort nicht mehr interessiert. Aber du bist verwundbar. Das ist der Grund. Vielleicht ist es auch so, vielleicht zieht es auch manche an. Was hast du gesagt? Ja, man ist verwundbar, man ist immer vor allem auch ein Freak. Man ist ein augenloser Freak mit so zwei weissen Strichen vor dem Auge. Beschlagen Sonnenbrillen dann auch? Ja, aber das ist ja egal. Sieht man ja da nicht, oder? Aber Brillenträger da draußen, geht es euch auch so? Schreibt es in die Kommentare. Schreibt es in die Kommis. Schreibt es mal in die Kommis. Das würde mich interessieren. Oder gibt es einfach einen Trick, das zu verhindern? Ja, kann man das nichtwischen? Beim Tauchen habe ich gelernt, ich habe mal so einen Tauchenlehrgang gemacht. Und da muss man reinspucken in die Taucherbrille. Reinspucken und verreiben. Ja, genau. Aber beschlagen Sie den innen oder außen? Nee, die Brille. Die Brille. Außen. Innen? Weiß ich nicht. Unsicher. Schwer. Ja, muss man auch. Aber ich weiß nicht, was das genau ist. Reflexartig puste ich dann da rein, aber es hilft halt auch nicht. So wie beim Tauchen, wo du ja, wenn du Wasser in der Brille hast und du bist unter Wasser. Ja, hat das verloren. Techniken. Du musst dann mit deinem Mund Luft nach oben blasen, also Blubberblasen machen, und dann hebst du die Taucherbrille unten so ein Stück ab, sodass die Luft in deine Brille kommt und das Wasser verdrängt und dann musst du wieder zumachen, sodass das Wasser verdrängt. Ja, weil es blubbert das ja so weg. Ja, wirklich. Es blubbert das weg. Ja, klar, so habe ich das gemacht. Ich habe Tauchkurs eins und zwei gemacht. Mit drei hätte man eine Flasche getaucht, aber ich habe nur eins und zwei gemacht. Weißt du, wie eine Bon funktioniert oder eine Shisha? Ich habe Angst, dir das zu erklären, Stefan. Ich will nicht, dass du die nächsten Fehlkäufe begehst. Du willst mich nicht hier plötzlich in der Ecke sitzen sehen, wenn du bei der Aufnahme kommst. Ich will nicht, dass du cool wirst. Sonst haben wir ein verdammtes Problem. Das ist nicht cool. Nee, das ist nicht cool. Bong ist nicht cool, Shisha ist nicht cool. Mich interessiert nur ernsthaft, wie das funktioniert. Es gibt doch jetzt von diesem Wiesource-Typen einen neuen YouTube-Kanal, wo er auch so Wissens macht. Und der heißt Dong. Dong. Ach so, nee. Der Wiesource-Typ hat für YouTube Red, das Bezahlformat für YouTube, hat er sämtliche Drogen getestet, unter ärztlicher Aufsicht. Und so stelle ich mir auch einen geilen Koksabend vor. Wirklich einfach mit diesem Krankenhauskittel an, neben einem alten Doktor, der kein Lachen, keine Freude im Gesicht hat, mir einfach per Infusion Koks irgendwie fadonisiert in die Blutbahn schießt und dann neben mir sagt, ja, jetzt ziehen wir ein bisschen runter von zehn, neun und gleich merken sie die Wirkung. Das ist meine Feiervorstellung. Ja, eigentlich so ein Anästhesist mehr, einfach der so zehn, neun. Aber das ist für mich ein geiler Drogenabend. Weißt du, was der beste Arzt ist? Christoph Waltz in Herr Lehmann. Der deutsche Film Herr Lehmann mit Christian Ulm, sehr guter Film, schaut euch an. Und da hat Christoph Waltz, noch vor seinem großen Durchbruch, vor seinen Oscars, hat eine kleine Rolle als Arzt. Und er ist der beste fucking Arzt der Welt. Christoph Weils schafft es ja ohnehin, also unfassbar sympathische Figuren zu spielen, die auch so sympathisch sind. Krasse Ehrlichkeit haben. Und dieser Arzt, sein Freund macht irgendwie drei Nächte durch, schläft drei Nächte nicht, und dann geht er zu diesem Arzt. Und wie er dem umgeht, ist es so cool. Ich wollte diesen Ausschnitt noch mal gucken, aber auf YouTube gibt es das nicht. Es gibt manche Filme, die gibt es auf YouTube fast vollständig in kleinen Clips und irgendwie, ah, geile Szene aus Troja oder was auch immer. Oder der Kampf aus Troja zwischen Hector und Achilles gibt es hundertmal auf YouTube. Aber diese gute Szene aus Herr Lehmann gibt es nicht. Das heißt, falls ihr irgendwie der Copyright das habt, Herr Ulmen, wenn sie zuhören, lade es hoch,
schaut euch Herr Ulmen an, Christoph Walz in Herr Ulmen,
ich weiß nicht warum,
in Herr Lehmann, ich weiß nicht warum, aber es ist so ein geiler Arzt
irgendwie und mit dem würde ich, unter dessen Aufsicht
würde ich auch Drohungen nehmen.
Ärzte sollten keinen Smalltalk betreiben,
finde ich. Ich will nicht, dass sie
irgendwie, ich will nicht wissen, wie die leben.
Man will Ärzten...
Und vor allem, man hat ja Ärzte so ein bisschen manchmal das Gefühl, die nehmen einen nicht so ernst. Überhaupt niemanden ernst. Und die bemuttern einen so ein bisschen. Sie sollten weniger Cholesterin essen und so. Und dieser Arzt von Christoph Walz ist halt so ein, ja, er war jetzt drei Tage lang wach, bringt dich auch nicht um, ist ja auch nicht jetzt verboten, drei Tage wach zu bleiben. Der war so ein, ja, der menschliche Körper hält ja schon aus, der war nicht so von oben herab nicht so von oben herab, sondern so, ja, wir gucken mal so an, welche haben sie denn Drogen genommen, welche Drogen nehmen sie denn so, so ganz so, man will dem alles sagen, weil der ist so, der betrachtet das gar nicht so moralisch, sondern einfach so, ich muss jetzt einfach wissen, welche Drogen sie genommen haben und, ja gut, bringt den jetzt auch nicht um, so Marihuana, also so ganz, ganz ohne Moral. Kann ich einfach nehmen, Maria? Doch, doch, ich glaube, dich bringt es tatsächlich um. Ich glaube, die Coolness würde einfach deine Synapsen zum Explodieren bringen. Kann gut sein. Weiß nicht. Ich bin da so zwiegespalten bei Marihuana. Weil, überleg mal, ganz tolle Kunst wurde auf Drogen geschrieben. Nein, wurde es nicht. Das ist eine der grössten Mythen, die ich ... Brian Wilson hat gesagt, Pat Sounds hat er quasi komplett auf Marihuana geschrieben. Und ohne Marihuana hätte es Pat Sounds nicht gegeben. Hat er gesagt, er war auch ein bisschen high in dem Interview wahrscheinlich. Aber, und das Marihuana spricht aus ihm, was mittlerweile ihn übernommen hat. Und man muss sagen, Sgt Pepper wurde auch komplett auf LSD geschrieben. Ich bin mir da nicht sicher. Man weiss nicht genau, was das bedeutet. Also haben die in der Zeit LSD genommen oder haben die wirklich beim kreativen Prozess LSD genommen? Ich glaube, das, genau das. Kommen da so produktive Sachen bei rum? Ja, augenscheinlich mega. Weil so crazy ist das jetzt nicht, also ich meine, für damals vielleicht. Was? Was? Naja, ich weiss nicht, ist es schwer einzuschätzen im historischen Konnektabler. Aber ich we weiß nicht, das ist ein Mythos, den ich nicht glaube. Und ich glaube, es wird über, weil es ist ja auch oft so, gerade wenn man, jetzt mal so im Unterhaltungs- oder Comedy-Bereich ist und man macht so eine, keine Ahnung, so eine Folge für Flickse-Klicks und dann schreibt jemand so, genau, dann schreibt jemand so etwas, oh, was die nehmen, würde ich auch gerne nehmen, wo man sich denkt so, nee, wir sind nicht auf Drogen. Trinkenglas,, Trinkenglas Wasser, M&M ist vorher runter. Ja, vor allem, dass sie davon ausging, jede Form von Verrücktheit käme von Drogen. Nein, das ist einfach das, was wir dort machen und präsentieren. Und es macht einen auch so ein bisschen die eigene Arbeit kaputt, weil der davon ausging, oh geil, die sind ja auf Drogen. Aber eigentlich ist das ja die eigene Kunst, die man da präsentiert. Das stimmt. Jede Woche bei Felflix und Klicks. Von daher ist Brian Wilson von den Beach Boys sehr uneitel, wenn er sagt, naja, die ganze Arbeit hat Marihuana gemacht, ich nicht. Brian Wilson ist ja ein sehr bescheidener Mensch, vielleicht ist das ja seine Art von Bescheidenheit, zu sagen, ja, wir haben da verrückte Drogen genommen, aber eigentlich ist er der Genie, der das alles in absolut rationalem, kühlen Kalkül runtergeschrieben hat. God only know what... Das ist ein Hammer-Song. Doch, ich wollte woanders einsteigen. Okay, drei, zwei... God only know what's love you. Okay, guter Song, aber es funktioniert noch nicht ganz. Schade, schade. Schade. Naja, ich wünsche euch noch einen fantastischen Abend, haut rein, schöne Woche noch. Nimmt mal die Beine in die Hand. Ja, okay. Das habe ich auch nie verstanden. Vielen Dank an Fritz Frittenfett noch mal für das Intro und vielen Dank an alle, die schon Intros eingeschickt haben. Gerne, wenn ihr Lust habt, Eugen Eugen zu schreiben, schickt sie uns ein. Ansonsten bin ich sehr gespannt. Macht was Verrücktes, macht was euch Spaß macht. Ansonsten bin ich sehr gespannt, was bei Stephans DNA-Test zurückkommt.
Ich hoffe, dass es nicht einfach zurückkommt und die Box geht auf und da steht einfach nur gross Krebs.
Oder gross Deutschland ausrufe. Was hast du erwartet, Deutschland ausrufe, bezeiht.
Auch so eine Handwritten Note.
Ja, ja.
Naja, wir werden sehen, ich bin sehr gespannt.
Macht's gut, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau.
Und wir heben ab, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschau. Und wir heben ab bis zum nächsten Mal. Ciao.